listen I I I gotta tell you you got I
think you got this uh relationship thing
figured out all right because I see you
got the multiples you got the Lou
Williams going on you know what I'm
saying I feel like every time I see you
got you know there's like a couple of
girlfriends is this one yeah see now but
see now I'm back in two so you got two
yeah and they both know about each other
they both together right now okay and
the way you said it like I got two like
that's not enough you know you like I
had three one of them I had them what'd
you do she had to go meaty what happened
what's she doing you had to get her out
of here yeah
was that the one who posted you sleeping
on Instagram nah that was cool
they'd be catching me plucking and [__]
but I'm cool with it cause like I'm you
know I'd like to be down to earth like
of course I like for people to know that
I ain't know you know what I'm saying
nonchalant type who don't who don't
accept my flaws who run from you know
what I'm saying they're lame to me